reçus par jean marc face à la première
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous merci de
nous rejoindre pour ce numéro de la
saison 2 face à la première émission qui
reviendra sous une forme d aménager un
très rapidement en début septembre
aujourd'hui un invité spécial les prix
vers raphaël confiant beaux jours afin
confiant jose marti qui a accepté notre
invitation de venir parler de son
dernier livre publié il ya quelques
semaines par les éditeurs caraïbes
édition une maison d'édition basée en
guadeloupe mais qui voyons évidemment
sur la martinique
un livre consacré à la vie à l'oeuvre de
franz fanon dont je donne le titre comme
vous pouvez déjà trouver en librairie
d'ailleurs l'insurrection de l'âme
frantz fanon vie et mort du guerrier
silex
donc je salue d'ailleurs la l'audace et
la prise de risque de caraïbes édition
est une petite entre guillemets maison
d'édition et qui a décidé de vous faire
confiance en son nom est ce que vous
pouvez nous tient compte quelles
conditions vous êtes entré
vous êtes mis d'accord avec l'éditeur
ans florent charbonnier base à voile au
près comme je le disais pour qu'il
accepte de publier ce livre
alors je travaille avec florent
charbonnier caraïbes édition depuis
plusieurs années déjà
cette maison d'édition en fait elle est
basée sur guadeloupe et martinique pas
seulement la guadeloupe bien sûr j'ai
publié plusieurs polars chez eux au
niveau universitaire je criais une
collection dans cette maison d'édition
qui a déjà publié près de cet ouvrage
donc c'est quand même un éditeur très
courage sérieux et qui malheureusement
dans ce pays où le livre est méprisé par
les politiques ne reçoit aucune aide
il fait des demandes est évidemment
parce que le livre a besoin d'être aidé
l'agriculture a besoin d'être aidés tous
les secteurs économiques et aucun
secteur économique qui n'a pas besoin
d'être est apparemment dans ce pays les
gens estiment que le livre n'a pas
besoin d'être donc il maintient à peine
la tête hors de l'eau
et quand vous me dites il a accepté de
publier ce livre
en fait c'est moi qui lieu proposé ce
livre parce que vous pensez bien que
j'aurais pu le proposer un grandes
maisons d'édition françaises
oui mais j'ai délibérément fait le choix
de le proposer à un éditeur local de
façon à pouvoir permettre quelque peu
même si ça sera insuffisant à cette
maison d'édition de tenir la route
mais là je lance vraiment un appel aux
politiques
le livret d'édition song en crise dans
ce pays depuis plusieurs années on a vu
disparaître des maisons d'édition celles
qui naissent le duo pas très longtemps
n'ont pas les moyens logistiques de se
faire connaître à l'extérieur il faut
vraiment qu'il ya des demandes qui sont
faites et apparemment il n'ya aucune
réponse quel que soit le régime en place
d'ailleurs inquiets que soient les
gouvernants je n'accuse personne en
particulier mais force est de constater
qu'au pays de césaire glissant de fanon
2 obel de chamoiseau enfin de deauville
d'alfred alexandre va personne n'a le
livre bon ben karim édition a fait cet
effort qui est un effort très lourd
parce que c'est quand même pas un livre
de 200 pages
oui en effet bon c'est ça la fabrication
de ce livre a dû coûter très cher 391
pas je vous apprécie le bon vin presque
400 balles bon ça a dû coûter très cher
l'éditeur prend un risque
ainsi le livre ne se vend pas bah c'est
lui qui paie c'est pas moi qui vais
payer les pots cassés avant de revenir
au contre les juifs je signale quand
même qui a plusieurs articles de presse
qui ont été consacrés jusqu'à tahiti
mais également à paris par exemple dans
le point dans lequel vous avez donné une
très longue interview vous entendu
récemment sur les médias audiovisuels
france inter ou tv5 monde par exemple
évidemment en martinique alors comme il
est de tradition dans notre émission
avant de parler du contenu de cette de
cette oeuvre avez vous un ou des faits
d'actualité récente qui vous a
particulièrement marqué un didier
intéressés si on plie ou amusé je vous
dise c'est tous les jours qu'il ya des
choses qui qui à la fois indigne j'aime
bien votre expression indigne la
dernière chose qui m'amuse indigne c'est
quand j'ai vu certainement un pêcheur
s'en prendre à un élu de la ctm au motif
que la réserve marine qui va être
installé va mettre en danger leur
activité mais je veux bien les croire
simplement l'installation des réserves
marines ne relève pas des collectivités
territoriales mais de l'état français
donc c'est tous les jours dans ce pays
qu'on voit des gens s'en prendre aux
collectivités locales sans savoir où en
faisant semblant de passable évidemment
que c'est que qu'il ya des domaines qui
sont régalien aussi le mot est
incompréhensible qui relève de l'état
français et si on a une revendication
qui relève de l'état français ça ne sert
à rien de monter à plateau roy ou de
s'en prendre publiquement un élu et moi
ça m'amuse mais ça m'indigne aussi parce
qu'il faut que dans ce pays des gens
prennent leurs responsabilités et
cessent de se comporter comme des
enfants d ati les compères l'ap
vous avez bien vu que lors des élections
législatives on avait beaucoup de
candidats qui n'avaient pas
niveau requis pour qu'ils ne savaient
même pas à quoi sert député quelles sont
ses domaines d'intervention donc ceci à
ses habituels fait rire vous croyez que
ceux qui ont été élus à parler de chimie
ont le niveau requis m'enfin bref eu
pète méchant poisson alors justement
revenons à notre frantz fanon déjà vous
allez nous décrypter le livre mais je le
titre pendant six mois le titre
une question déjà inauguré en quelque
sorte vous vous innovez parce que vous
avez créé une autobiographie imaginaire
à savoir que vous n'êtes ni à la place
en partie en tout cas dans le livre la
place du personnage que vous voulez donc
vous le raconter la vie frantz fanon
auto biographie imaginaire
qu'est ce qui vous a pris d'un côté je
me suis rendu compte que fan en était
devenu juste un nom de rue de lys et de
collège en févier tech et que même ceux
qui font semblant de le citer si
toujours la même citation chaque
génération doit assumer bla bla bla je
me suis dit qu'il faudrait peut-être que
je suis enseignant sur le campus je m'en
rends compte qu'il ya une désaffection
pour la lecture qui est très forte et
donc je me suis dit que s'il y avait
peut-être un moyen de ramener les gens
et surtout les jeunes 1
la lecture des oeuvres de falun ça
serait peut-être que de donner de leur
donner à vos flancs de l'intérieur
c'est à dire non pas de l'extérieur se
confondant tous les universitaires 1 il
ya des milliers de tels ouvrages des
centaines d'ouvragés
enfin dans toutes les grandes du monde
d'ailleurs puisque fanon c'est l'un des
martiniquais avec ses airs et glissant
qui sont les plus connues celles et ceux
qui nous font exister qui font cette
minuscule tête d'épinglé martinez qui
existent dans le monde ce qu'il ya c'est
tout de même un pays de ma quatre cent
mille habitants aujourd'hui qui est
autant connu dans le monde par an 3,3 de
ses penseurs et et en même temps
militant politique
tout à fait c'est à dire que quel que
soit l'endroit du monde
invité dans les endroits assez
improbable je me rappelle à l'université
de pécs en hongrie pêche est la deuxième
ville de hongrie
et puis à l'université de séoul en corée
du sud quand on m'a présenté on a dit
que je venais de fanon les étudiants
gauchistes one augmenté mais nous de
marquer des parts dans les études hier
bauchi ce tout au fond de la salle ont
tout de suite dit phalanx fanon les
damnés de la terre dans leur langue bien
sûr ils l'interprètent m'a dit voilà ils
connaissent nos deux pays parce que il
ya les damnés de la terre de la fa lun
donc sauf que dans son pays et ce qui
les lui c'est ça la question est ce que
les gens ont ouvert les damnés de la
terre pour la révolution africaine en
fait tous et expand en manteau pour
noire masques blancs
voilà égrillard peut-être c'est celui
qui le monde on peut dire un peu du
week-end il ya des générations du nouvel
an qui sont aujourd'hui une désaffection
je me suis dit que l'on peut continuer à
faire des travaux universitaires soufan
il ya des centaines comme je les dix
ouvrages on voit l'auteur de l'extérieur
par contre si on se met à sa place si on
essaie de s'imaginer ce qu'il a vécu et
c'est pour ça que l'ouvragé commence par
fans en agonisant sur son lit d'hôpital
dans cet hôpital du maryland aux états
unis où il en train de mourir de la
leucémie à 36 ans donc
l'ouvragé commence par cet homme qui
sent la vie s'évader peu à peu de lui et
qui revit toute sa brève mais fulgurante
aventure qu'est ce que cela vous parler
à la première personne ce sont les
premières pages du livre assez poignante
qui vous m qui vous jettent directement
dans le bouquin comment avez vous pu
reconstituer cette scène parce qu'elle a
les traits plus connus y avait très peu
de monde y avait très peu de témoins à
part le personnel hospitalier
des représentants du gouvernement
provisoire algérien et puis sa proche
famille son fils et sa famille comment
avez vous pu supposer que c'est comme ça
que cette scène aurait dû se dérouler
mais il faut faire preuve d'empathie
d'abord ça ne suffit pas bien sûr il
faut ce qu'on peut appeler le miracle de
la littérature
c'est à dire que cette volonté d'
empathie et première allan j quand même
eu cette chance d'avoir pu vite 2 en
alger d'avoir essayé de suivre les
traces de fanon avec bien d'autres noms
comme on choisit qui a été récemment
couronné par le 31e congrès mondial des
études francophones comme genre il est
hautain fano et sur toute une génération
10 ans ou 12-15 rappelé à la fin de la
guerre d'algérie voulons suivre les pas
de fanon et donc j'ai connu de près le
peuple algérien j'ai visité l'hôpital
psychiatrique de blida ou fanon a existé
je sais a exercé pendant est donc ce ce
son périple ne met pas totalement
extérieures ça aurait plus difficile
était plus difficile
si je n'avais pas pas impossible mais
plus difficile
si je n'avais pas vécu quand même deux
ans à gilles ceci m'a facilité un peu
les choses mais enfin il faut quand même
pouvoir se mettre dans la peau de
quelqu'un
ce qui n'est pas dit ce qui n'est pas
chose aisée à l'eau départ j'ai voulu
écrire le livre totalement au jeu et
qu'au bout d'un moment pris de remords
je me suis dit mais qui suis-je pour
pouvoir prétendre remplacer trudel
parler totalement au nom d'une
personnalité aussi puissante dont 6
pouces apple ouvrage à certains moments
à des passages aux îles narrateur c'est
à dire que je serai plus là dans en
substance celui de la liste lui d'une du
critique si je me dis voilà ce de la
prise de distance avec le personnage
fanon et finalement ça construit une
espèce de texte un puzzle
parce que je crois que la vie humaine
est un puzzle ce n'est jamais un long
fleuve tranquille une ligne droite
alors quand je lis les biographies qu'on
le lit en trouve partout en librairie
vous avez l'impression que la vie d'un
tel jet pas mois dernier soit là ou de
dumas quand on fait des biographies
chronologique que salants fleuve
tranquille mais la vie est faite de zig
zag d'imprévus de et la courte vie de
fanon a été faite de 2,2
de sérieuses il alors justement un
pardon parlons sans qu'ils aient france
and go qui était-il je rappelle qu'il
est né en 1925 des ces derneirs 161
l'âge de 36 ans victime de la leucémie
qui n'a pas pu faire soigner comme à
l'époque la mode d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
encore elle a lui signé très difficiles
à guérir alors est ce que on peut dire
qu'on dépense ce jeune homme en or apple
qui l'a fait partie de la de la
dissidence autres elle voulait faire
partir de là 19 de ces jeunes femmes et
hommes
les antilles et de la guyane donc sous
domination française qui était
volontaire bompard antillon sa marque
sur le front européen contre les nazis
comment arrive-t-il à se rebeller
finalement contre le colonialisme
français c'est ce qu'on a va essayer de
comprendre
mais tout d'abord ses années de jeunesse
c'est tout de même étonnant de voir que
fanon comme tous les autres noms n'a que
rêve à l'âge de 18 ans ce n'est pas anti
ou se battre contre l'horaire l'horreur
représenté par déclarer et ses comparses
oui parce qu'à l'époque fanon les cris
des jeunes apollons hamas comme un
élément technique et ce sont deux
français sans sans inquiétude sans
interrogation fall en lui même ici parce
bad serbe contre le nazisme mais ils
parlent se battre aussi pour la france
de l'assimiler comme on dirait
aujourd'hui tous les martiniquais à
l'époque était assimilé faut pas que en
face comment dirais-je d'anachronisme
le terme assimilé que nous employons
aujourd'hui et puis jour hâtif mais il
n'était pas péjoratif à l'époque
puisqu'il y avait une volonté
d'assimilation
je rappelle que cissé et wright et leur
apport durant 46 de la loi dite de
départementalisation entre guillemets
assimilation la revendication
d'assimilation date de la fin du 19e
siècle le siècle auparavant quasi gay de
bons donc c'est passé bon donc assimilés
allait enfin l'amour de la france je
veux dire mais aussi la volonté de se
battre contre l'ignominie nazis ont fait
qu'à l'âge de 18 ans ce jeune homme sans
rien dire à son père s'embarque sur un
canot pas en dominique pour rejoindre
les forces françaises libres
c'est quand même pas rien
et est arrivé à dominique
malheureusement il ne peut pas rejoindre
les forces françaises libres et il
revient à la martinique où il est enrôlé
comme soldat volontaire
donc il y avait les décideurs donc les
engage les civils jallet nous a engagés
volontaires et puis avait les soldats
militaires du contingent ou à la soldats
professionnels qui eux
mako l'essentiel voulait se battre
effectivement sur le front européen
donc il parle sur le front européen il
fait son premier séjour en afrique du
nord d'ailleurs parce que les troupes
qui partent des antilles ou d'amérique
font font escale en afrique du nord
avant de passer par la corse et ensuite
le sud de la france la provence et de
remonter il est blessé dans les vosges
et les citer il est almeida et enfin
c'est un ancien combattant comme comme
ceux qu'on voit défiler à tous les défis
lors de toutes les fêtes dites
nationales et alors qu'il interrompt de
ses études comme beaucoup de jeunes
filles deux hommes est bon qu ici on
vive qui sont pas rock'n'roll
j'allais dire une vie déjà très remplie
parce qu'à 18 19 20 ans bon on a déjà
fait la guerre on a vu l'horreur de
cancer tient au but les camps
d'extermination nazis
et ils l'auront vient en martinique et
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui va se passer à
ce moment là parce qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent quelque chose de sa vie mais
écoutez pensez-y passe son baccalauréat
et là ils demandent une bourse vous
faire des études en france et chose
assez terrible cette bourse lui est
refusée parce qu'il appartient à petite
bourgeoisie comme elle en tire quelques
voilà voilà
et donc il doit se battre et c'est
finalement il obtient cette bourse de
plus de force que je grille je dirais de
la part des autorités
et finalement il va faire ses études à
lyon et il fait ses études de médecine
mais un terreau il s'intéresse davantage
à la psychiatrie donc il passe son
diplôme et dans des conditions assez
difficiles devaient assez difficile
parce que la bourse ne suffit pas bien
sûr on est dans l'après-guerre en france
les étudiants sont logés dans des
conditions effroyables les anciennes
maisons closes de l'occupation en fait
c'est des choses affreuses m'enfin ils
arrivent à tenir le coup il passe son
doctorat et leur vie alors à vendre
ils y passent juste déjà un point
important il va à lyon il aurait pu
aller comme beaucoup d'antillais à paris
à bordeaux
pourquoi aliot qu'est ce qui sert hazard
cci l'été fléchir voir il avait été
conseiller parce qu'il ya très peu
d'antillais a lieu en ce moment en tout
cas il y avait une volonté chez lui
d'échapper quelques pas au côté un peu
étouffant du micro cause régionale je
dirais parce que quand vous allez dans
une ville où il ya beaucoup de vos
compatriotes vous découvrez que la ville
vous découvrez que la riche on restera 3
soit voilà et donc
moi ça me rappelle que moi j'étais faire
mes études et à aix-en-provence dans les
années soixante quinze mille et les
années 70 il y avait très peu de tirs ce
qui m'a énormément aidé à fréquenter les
autres communautés jouer était à
toulouse ou à palau à bordeaux jouez
jamais joué au jeu game contactons et je
pense que c'est ça qui a joué et quelque
part il y avait déjà une sourde défiance
envers le bal boudin à crash d'hier est
encore une volonté d'émancipation
émancipation en est à combattre si on
l'attend émancipation sortir de son
milieu et pas du tout aux visions bien
ici un du tourisme
alors de qui revient martinique vous
disiez avant que je vous interrompez il
essaie de s'installer comme médecin
qu'il est et qu'il y voit là il fait
d'abord un stage à l'hôpital
psychiatrique de colson très brièvement
et ensuite il nous vend cabinet au plein
ce qui veut s'installer à son pays donc
les gens qui disent ah oui fanaye la
mandoline a menti ning pour aller vivre
dans le jeu ils connaissent rien c'est
pas vrai a nom est revenu s'installer
ici et nero et mais pas même pas à fort
de france à nice et installez-vous
quelques jours vous dit le vauclin joue
dur imposant que c'est tout près mais on
est dans les années un faux pas c'est un
périple
ça prend plus d'une heure en fait les
routes sont en mauvais état et puis bon
il arrive expédition voilà les il arrive
là bas ils ou son cabinet et il
s'aperçoit que ses collègues médecins
n'ont qu'un profond mépris pour une
population qui à l'époque est très
pauvre il y avait beaucoup d'indigents
comme on disait qu'il y avait des gens
qui avaient des cartes d'indigents
d'ailleurs disant qu'ils n'ont aucun
moyen de et surtout il y avait les
fameux bons mg aide médicale gratuite et
est donc fans on est révolté par toute
cette misère ambiante et il essaie avec
ses collègues de mettre en place un
système de visites à domicile des gens
qui peuvent pas et les gens lui et ses
collègues lui rit au nez quoi et ça doit
arriver à allécher les gens fermés des
visites au lieu de les faire venir au
bond du voka pas le tour bus à les
pompes attaque si je vous dis que c'est
difficile mais qui sont ses collègues
ses confrères médecins à l'époque ben
moi je ne peux pas les nommer
le palais s'est débarrassé d'ivoire n'en
fait pas c'est pas c'est pas d'aider ces
gens de france sont des martiniquais
évidemment c'est la peur de la
bourgeoisie naissante se sont pas des
métros comme on dit aujourd'hui enfin
l'époque on disait des blancs france un
nom ce sont des martiniquais et wallon
est absolument révolté il dit je quitte
la martinique ce pays où il y a plus de
pantalons que d'hommes c'est terrible
alors vous me direz c'est encore plus
terrible aujourd'hui parce qu'elle-même
plus de bataillon qui a créé des
caleçons mais en fait c'est pas grave
chanson du un des candidats sur votre
antenne parler de call surnage bon il
n'a pas été élu mais bon si fan on était
là aujourd'hui le 10ème et ccc finit
donc fans ont dégoûté quitte la rente
inique et 952 voix ses 22 53 et il
retourne en france et il va dans une
région isolée alors on compte d'un grand
professeur de psychiatrie le professeur
toscer qui en réfugie un républicain
réfugiés espagnols et qui a créé une
nouvelle forme de thérapie qu'il appelle
la sociale thérapie qui naissent plus
d'innovation en matière de psychiatrie
pour l'époque et il se forme au contact
de ce professeur tosquelles il accueille
un les bases de la social thérapie qui
en contradiction avec la la psychiatrie
officiel un bien sûr puisque la
médiathèque est officiel michel foucault
bien après la dénoncera synpics ce qui a
fait qu'ils considèrent que les fous
quelque part son incurable quelle qu'en
soit des malades avis à quelqu'un
oui parce que vous les mettez en hôpital
psychiatrique il faut des camisoles de
force il faut leur donner toutes sortes
de produits chimiques pour l'heure les
abrutir pendant la journée pour qu'il ne
crie pas au quine et ses fans ont
totalement opposées à cela qui va il va
rejoindre ce bruit ça qui est
complètement isolé nous ont reconnus
oui clinquante de la lozère du voile aux
héritiers pas français qui espagnol qui
survit comme il n'a pas de poste en
france
je ne sais même pas si je les mets dans
l'oise ce profit surtout ce qu'elle
survit grâce un salaire versé par le
gouvernement mexicain
j'ai craint va c'est étonnant parce
qu'en france on a refusé mais assure
quand type aussi révolutionné au plan
psychiatrique soit exerce donc voilà et
donc une fois que fanon hasan sas son
diplôme en psychiatrie xt il passe tous
ses examens pour devenir médecin cette
fois psychiatrie réussi brillamment y
trouve sa voie voilà il se dit je vais
en afrique mans l'an quand tous les gens
qui disent ah oui fans d'aller se battre
avec les arabes
il a délibéré sur l'afrique noire etc
arrêtons ceci n'est pas vrai fan on a
écrit à monsieur léopold sédar senghor
alors président de la république du
sénégal pour lui dire voilà je
souhaiterais travailler dans l'hôpital
psychiatrique de dakar n'a jamais eu de
réponse
bon tout le monde sait que dès cette
époque fans ont été déjà un peu sourire
parce que vous quittez la martinique
avec fracas vous allez globaux fait
surtout ce qu'elle est c'est donc 5 go
ne te connaît la fin la trajectoire en
tout cas ne pouvait pas accepter
quelqu'un puis à l'académie française
voile et la normandie mais est ce que
oui mais bon alors il l'a pourquoi
arrivent et forcément parce que aussi sa
mort était un communiqué john ami ou un
proche de 16e auxquels j'allais dire
l'admiration puisque même oui oui il
voulait à saisir une grande admiration
au respect tout en étant déjà critique
quelques pas sûr parce que c était déjà
député bien sûr mairie le terrain et il
ne le dit pas clairement mais il le
laissant en cinq bornes pas répondu mais
volontairement fait parce que vous
pouvez signifié un refus sans répondre
et et de guerre lasse ils nous regardent
les postes disponibles à l'époque
algérie était un département français
composé de trois dépend énormément et
voilà
l'ecri donc un yoga qui sont les postes
disponibles on a habité connaît rien de
la jso ce bref passage lors de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
il écrit et puis là on lui dit écoutez
monsieur d'accord parole il débarque
avec sa femme judy française en algérie
à l'hôpital psychiatrique de leader
libyen qui est une ville qui est
nostalgique qui n'est pas la capitale
qui n'est pas la capitale
la capitale règne la psychiatrie cologna
dans un hôpital après l'hôpital mustapha
où existe le plus grand psychiatre entre
guillemets coloniaux qui ont une théorie
tout à fait raciste sur l'algérien ou
l'arabe primitif ayant des crises de
folie régulier avec ses enfants et il
lui fallait il débarque dans un milieu
qui ne connaît pas et ils découvrent
cette horreur
parce que l'hôpital psychiatrique de
blida c'est une petite ville et c'est à
dire que je sais pas un point matinée
imaginer dillon complète transformer
complètement en hôpital psychiatrique la
plaine de 10 l'an il ya plus d'immeubles
et c'est à l'arrière des bâtiments
partout des pavillons il y avait 3000
malades je sais pas si vous rendez
compte
et c'était pas des immeubles cédés
pavillon alors il y avait le pavillon
des hommes européens
le pavillon des femmes européennes le
pavillon des hommes musulmans et le
pavillon des femmes musulmanes et tout
ça est allé à tel point qu'il fallait se
déplacer en voiture pour aller d'un bout
à l'autre que de cet hôpital est très
vite fans en est révolté par les
méthodes qui sont employés qui vont à
l'encontre bien sûr de la social théâtre
alors dans votre livre vous reconstituer
des dialogues empreints le thème
reconstituer parce que en fait il ya pas
d archives écrites des conversations
orange aux qu'il a avec ses chefs de
service avec ses collègues avec lequel
il tente de les convaincre du bien fondé
de nouvelles méthodes de traitement des
fous parce que là nous ne sommes pas
dans le fan en politique c'est vraiment
le médecin le psychiatre qui sait et on
le considère tellement
peu qu'on lui confie le pavillon des
européennes
et puis des musulmans parce que
finalement on lui dit allez va te casser
les dents commencent à nous faire avec
ton histoire de théories fumeuses et
donc on le subit et du mépris de
l'ostracisme de la part de la plupart de
ses collègues à ce moment là oui de la
direction de l'hôpital aussi parce que
il va à l'encontre des méthodes qui sont
employés il est contre le fait
d'utiliser la camisole de force
le fait d'utiliser des psychotropes pour
les médicaments qui abrutit serait
malade et il veut innover surtout au
niveau des musulmans en intégrant leurs
cultures l'eau croyance dans la thérapie
ce qui était nouveau
parce qu'on a appliqué une thérapie
occidental à des malades qui ne l'était
pas en faisant comme si les algériens
étaient des européens bien sûr ça ne
marchait pas donc lui il va sa portée de
ce moment là qu'il va se rapprocher de
la culture algérienne grâce à aux
infirmiers qui sont pour la plupart des
algériens
si tous les médecins des français voilà
des français d'alger et bien sûr parmi
lesquels beaucoup de juifs quittent les
amis de fans d'ailleurs et qui n'était
pas du tout d'accord avec la la la
psychiatrie coloniale pour beaucoup
d'entre eux eh bien il va là il va
visiter le pays
grâce à ces infirmiers il va aller
visiter la kabylie le village y va il va
écouter les compteurs il va s'imprégner
de la culture arabo berbère et il va
tenir compte de cette culture dans les
thérapies qu'il va mettre en oeuvre et
il aura du succès ce qui va étonner à la
fois la direction de l'hôpital et ses
collègues et ses collègues
alors ça c'est l'aspect visible sauf que
rapidement le front de libération
nationale a repéré fans ans et a pris
contact secrètement avec lui pour lui
demander de soigner le travestissement
les moudjahidine c'est à dire les les
les combats croix de trouver leur
libération nationale qui sont blessés et
que fan en fait entrer un peu quand
l'estimant à l'hôpital pour les soigner
et ce qu'il a fait de manière secrète
pendant au moins deux ans et à ce moment
là je considère que dès ce moment là il
devient dissidents par rapport au
système français qu'on m'avait posé la
question tout la leur
qu'il a fait la guerre contre la france
c'est pas quand les partis en tunisie
c'est déjà quand il prend le risque
énorme de soigner à l'hôpital de blida
les moudjahidine qui sont blessés et que
bon il risque la peine de mort n'est pas
un bon lien personnes 20 mai il y a des
il y aura des militants français ou
algériens physique est exécuté à wana la
guerre d'algérie qui commence le 1er
novembre le jour de la saint grat 1954
voir un nom et un poste là et à ce
moment là il prend conscience et il
devient plus à ce moment il 2009 au fur
et à mesure le militant politique de
fait
ah oui oui c'est vrai que il devient
membre clandestins quelque part de
l'armée de libération fin du front de
libération nationale et ses compétences
médicales sont mises sont mises en
oeuvre pour aider n'est ce pas le
mouvement s'était quand même très
difficile parce que tu as un million de
colons en algérie de pinon je sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte il y a une
armée française puissante qui est
présente
si vous avez des maquisards qui la
harcèle dans les les
dans les villages ou dans les montagnes
seng asymétriques comme on dit
aujourd'hui difficile de sorte que c'est
quand même prendre un risque énorme que
ce que fanon a fait mais il l'a fait en
toute connaissance de cause et jamais à
aucun moment dans son existence à brève
existence du dollar au great jamais à
quel moment ce sont gilles à la rupture
définitive si je puis dire avec le
système parce qu'à un moment donné ils
obligés de partir de paix des chaînes
comme oui alors il a le temps de s'en
aller et de rejoindre le gouvernement
provisoire de la république algérienne à
tunis avant qu'ils ne soient licenciés
il dit
c'est à dire que il vit alors là il y
aura une controverse là dessus et aux
athlètes connaissent pas
du gouverneur de l'algérie lui
signifiant que lire envoyés en métropole
comme on disait à l'époque et ya une
controverse selon laquelle il serait
parti à la suite de cette lettre mais ce
n'est pas vrai fan on est parti quelques
temps avant cette lutte il a rejoint
immédiatement le gouvernement provisoire
de la république algérienne à tunis où
il est devenu l'un des principaux
rédacteurs de la version francophone du
journal du parti à londres hyde et on a
des photos de lui n'a pas beaucoup de
photos de lui
les rares photos qu'on a de lyon le voit
au comité de rédaction n'est ce pas à
côté de karim belkacem enfin à côté de
tous les chefs de la révolution
algérienne est entré et souvent les
articles n'étaient pas signés
mais ce qu on reconnaît le style
quelqu'un qui sait lire reconnaît le
style de fans alors autre particularité
de ce personnage haut en couleur c'est
sensé son style littéraire parce que
avant d'arriver à tous que nous
décrivons là il a déjà écrit un livre
qui a fait sensation au sens propre du
terme peau noire masques blancs publié
aux éditions du seuil à paris en 1952
donc il en train de finir ses études de
psychiatre avant de partir en algérie
et là on voit dans son style on peut
relire aujourd'hui ils sont soixante ans
plus de 60 ans après un style
particulier n'ont pas contrôlé mais un
peu dithyrambique ces voix très fleuri
mais extrêmement précis il décrit des
choses de manière très précise pour nos
masques blancs qui est en quelque sorte
un essai sur les raisons et les
conséquences de la li na tion du noir
par rapport aux bleus c'est à dire qu'il
a voulu présenter peau noire masques
blancs comme test de doctorat
ce qui était une audace extraordinaire
puisqu'il s'agit d'un essai et c'était a
été
dédaigneusement et publiquement rejeté
par les membres du jury est il fan on
s'est résolu à écrire une autre côté en
deux mois classique je dirais sur un
sujet très très abscons dont le titre
m'échappe mais qui très psychiatrique et
finalement ils passent en ouverture plus
conventionnel voilà t il pas son nom et
n'abandonne pas les choses il se dit je
vais publier cet ouvrage est donc le
publie alors quand vous parlez du style
il faut savoir que fallon n'était pas
quelqu'un qui aimait s'asseoir devant
une table et puis est clairement ou
taper à la machine c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui aimait dictée donc il dictait à sa
femme ou le dicter à ses assistantes et
marchons comme un lion en cage et après
le roi lisez nous a travaillé dans ce
style un peu comme vous dites très haute
en couleurs il vient du fait que ça
style physique c'est à dire que c'est la
voix qui parle c'est c'est tout leur
corps majine son texte avant l'heure
c'est pas à taxer que ce sont pas même
son dernier livre les damnés de la terre
peut bien 61 ans et sa femme judy et
puis une assistante qui l'avait à
l'hôpital psychiatrique de la manouba à
tunis à qui dictait le texte est bon il
a souvent agi comme ça et c'est ce qui
donne à ces ses textes puissants parce
qu'il ya un espèce de commander une
corporéité dire les philosophes dans ce
texte indique les texans ont habité par
son corps ce qui pave quittant la façon
expérience pendant sa vision alors donc
non je rappelle que nous sommes sur
martin première vague raphaël confiant
qui vient de publier la surrection de
l'homme frantz fanon vite aimant du
guerrier silex consacré à la vie à
l'oeuvre de fans ont publié chez
caraïbes édition donc nous revenons aux
fans aux militants politiques vous dites
qu'il est l'un des principaux rédacteurs
de la version francophone du journal el
moudjahid le combattant le journal du
front de libération nationale d'algérie
mais il ne peut pas vivre en algérie
donc il est en exil avec le gp sera le
gouvernement provisoire de la république
algérienne à tunis la capitale de la
tunisie est fan on devient également un
ambassadeur itinérant
de ce mouvement révolutionnaire algérien
à prendre ça pose pas de problème aux
dirigeants julien que ce soit un jeune
algérien qui vient de l'autre côté de la
planète qui représente qui le représente
dans les instances internationales when
you are so lu ment pas d'ailleurs il va
dans plusieurs pays le niger le mali
tout ça et ils essayent n'est ce pas de
deux fours mentez ou d'aider les
mouvements révolutionnaires là bas et
comme l'armée française installé des
barrières électrifiées un moment les
lignes challe et morice du nombre de
généraux français le long des frontières
algéro marocaines et algéro tunisienne
pour empêcher que les maquisards les
willaya soit soit les maquis soit soit
fourni en armes
eh bien ils essaient de passer par le
sahara ce qui d'une audace folle à
l'époque transportent des armes par
carat 20 le chameau à partir du mali et
du niger pour remonter et c'est
d'ailleurs à cette époque il rencontre
celui qui est encore le président
l'algérie aujourd'hui abdelaziz
bouteflika est il qu'ils rentrent en
contact avenue et bouteflika avait une
grande admiration pour frantz fanon l'a
écrit d'ailleurs bon il était pas ce
qu'il est devenu
vous savez les hommes de pouvoir change
mais bon je parle de bouteflika de 60
rue du mort vivant qui à alger
aujourd'hui évidemment
alors donc une nouvelle aventure dans
dans sa vie déjà content très compliqué
de concilier sa vie personnelle avec sa
vie politique
comment sa famille restée au pays
et considérer comment elle vit ce que
parce que désormais c'est connu
maintenant c'est un art unique le moment
même si c'est pas toute la population
mais on sait que fanon et en décidant à
double titre qui l'a quitté son poste à
l'hôpital psychiatrique alors qu'ils y
étaient fonctionnaires là il est passé à
l'ennemi il ne peut plus revenir
un martini qui ne peut plus revenir en
france continentale je suis parce que
ses parents ses frais en dû vivre des
moments difficiles très difficile très
difficile parce que mais c'est ce qui
arrive est aussi à d'autres dissidents
plus jeune que lui daniel boukman
guadeloupe roulante et auros ou alors
sony wii perles sigean était condamné à
mort pour haute trahison
donc quand votre fils est condamné à
mort pour trahison et que vous êtes a
menti quand guadeloupe
la vie n'est pas très belle pour parce
que vous êtes surveillés on essaie de
vous mettre des bâtons dans les roues on
peut pas vous en faire mais parce que
c'est pas vous qui êtes à l'est d'alger
et vous battre mais la vie est quand
même très difficile mais il ya une
grande dignité dans la famille de fans
on s'est dit qu'ils n'ont jamais cédé
n'est ce pas aux pressions ou aux
menaces kg et ils ont été faits dix ans
sont toujours restés dix ils ont
toujours considéré que la trajectoire de
l'offreur de l'office ou de le re cousin
était une trajectoire qu'il avait
délibérément choisi sur des bases
claires et que eux ils n'avaient pas à
critiquer ceni à l'approuver
publiquement l'ample bien sûr mais si
j'appelle ça une attitude digne pendant
le tout ce périple de fans ont jusqu'à
son décès en 1961 comme en martinique
cela est vécu par les autres formations
politiques vous par les intellectuels on
le disait tout à l'heure que falloir une
grande animation procès rcr lui rend
hommage
une fois qu'il est décédé c'est vrai
qu'elle est si l'excellent appelle-t-il
ça fait ça fait partie du titre de votre
livre
mais pendant
hansson oui sens comme un device ans le
fait entre 1956 et 61 enfin dans le
martiniquais est devenu fan en algérien
est ce qu'il ya eu un écho ici
est ce qu'il ya eu une reprise ce qu'il
a fait des émules comme c'était ce
n'était pas facile comme aujourd'hui il
n'y avait pas d'internet y avait pas de
meslier pas de téléphone portable
c'était que les nouvelles étaient quand
même difficile je suis pas sûr que
l'ensemble de la population je suis même
persuadé que non elle était pas
tellement au courant de l'après je
trouve ça bien avant un petit milieu
intellectuel avis voilà les dirigeants
politiques water oui mais quelque part
fall angers n'est les embarras c'est
donc il y avait une espèce de silence à
son encontre je rappelle que par deux
fois il a rencontré césaire lors des
deux congrès des écrivains noirs
on a eu un pari un autre à rome en
italie et bien sûr c'est comme si je
puis en 1960 voilà les au cours de ces
deux congrès des artistes écrivains
noirs
il a eu l'occasion de rencontrer senghor
etc etc et ses discours enflammés en
faveur de la guerre d'algérie ou
profondément déplu évidemment ces hommes
qui étaient dans une posture de
compromis avec la france c'est à dire
que cinq gorrite et un député français
un bien sûr et indépendant voilà et tout
ce qu'il voulait c'était une
indépendance aller où les la
françafrique d'abord je la place à
l'union franco africaines
ça n'a pas marché monde a eu
l'indépendance m'en fait dans une lignée
des pronostics semblent départements
d'outre-mer de bon donc il fallait
quelque part gênait quant à césaire
vu la situation très difficile qui lui
était faite ici parce qu'ils m'ont quand
même membre du parti communiste et même
si après 58 la grille le ppm en fait
c'était le pouvoir français vous voyez
une très mauvaise et le parti communiste
et ensuite le ppm donc c était quand
même
c'est plus facile point combattants
révolutionnaires d'être intransigeant
quand vous êtes au pouvoir même si c'est
un pouvoir un peu factice ou local ouvre
portes vous proposez vous êtes obligé de
fond parce que ces rumeurs il est député
vous êtes obligés de composer pouvait
pas être révolutionné et puis assis sur
les bancs de velours rouge de
l'assemblée nationale c'est pas possible
ou alors vous venez vous est joué vous
parle fait quoi bon donc quelque part
ces deux positions très différentes
positionnement très différents enfin
annoncé le révolutionner intransigeant
qui ne serait jamais devenu ni mère ni
députés tant que la banque unique ne
serait pas indépendante et je ne suis
même pas sûr qu'il aurait accepté un
poste politique parce que quand il était
à tunis
il disait à ses camarades si jamais je
suis au vie à ma leucémie après
l'indépendance de l'algérie je ne veux
aucun post ni 2010 l'ambassadeur ni rien
je veux retourner à blida pour pratiquer
la seule chose que j'aime c'est le
psychiatre
donc c'est pas quelqu'un qui avait une
ambition politique
donc il gênait beaucoup gêné à tel point
que lorsqu'il a demandé à ses airs de
bien vouloir rédigé la préface des
damnés de la terre
il a eu une fin de non recevoir
il s'est alors adressé à jean paul
sartre et j'appelle ça qui était un type
extraordinaire du a dit bon ben écoutez
je vous fais cette préface en l'espace
d'une nuit tuant par le simple un grand
philosophe français voilà juste qui a
dominé la scène politique française
jusqu'aux années 1990 en voilà et lors
d'une nuit extraordinaire dans un hôtel
de rome il avait du charme côte-à-côte
douzy et phrasés et simone de beauvoir
la femme de centre est lui bien centre
écrivait cette préface qui énorme ainsi
pris face de trois pages l'exode prix
fasse toute la nuit et toutes les
demi-heures voyait les feuillets nous
avons signé d'accord voilà
il a appelé sa femme le castor simone de
beauvoir en grande féministe devant
l'éternel écrit le deuxième sexe ils
envoyaient simone d'un chambre porter
les deux pages qu'il a écrite phalanx
relisez faisait dé danza notation et
josy sa femme porte donc les deux femmes
ont servi toute la nuit et au matin
après avoir écrit une centaine de pages
il y avait les yeux complètement
exorbités et rouge ait fana et et cette
préface a été un bien et un mal
elle a été un bien parce que la paire
mais vu la renommée de sorte que vous
venez de rappeler nos normes
internationales pas seulement française
elle a donné tout de suite une une
portée extraordinaire aux damnés de la
terre
je suis pas sûr allez tout le respect
qu'on peut avoir ou cr suis pas sûr que
si c est l avait préfacé sas auront été
perçue comme un ouvrage plus
intellectualisme moins engagé parce que
ça que lui-même en france était une
espèce d'activistes ans alors d'être un
politicien que les est revenue sur la
scène politique voilà bon il
rappelez-vous que de gaulle avait dit on
en fait un pas voltaire quand on avait
voulu l'arrêter ce qui est intervenu
devant les usines renault pour appeler à
la révolution
eh bien ça donne une renommée
extraordinaire aux damnés de la terre
nyon nommé mondiales immédiates et c'est
parce que c'était préfacé par ça c'est
le bon côté de la chose de cette préface
et puis à le côté un peu moins bon je
dirais centre avait cette habitude de
préfacer beaucoup de gens qu'il
appréciait en extrayant un élément fort
du dolder du texte qu'il brille pas
c'est le montant en épingle jeudi le
mettant en exergue
si bien que dans les damnés de la terre
qu'est ce qu'il met en exergue la
violence alors oui bon virus du colonisé
contre le colonisateur voilà un bon coup
l'on est encore long mort enfin bon des
phrases terribles et malheureusement
c'est pour ça qu'il est important de
relever les gens croient que ses fans
ans qui a dit ça
jamais écrit ça c'est jean paul sartre
qui a écrit ça mais cette fois c'était
tellement puissante était tellement
connu que quelques pas se trouver face à
un peu phagocyter le texte la occulter
quelques pas et on a une vision 4
caricaturale d'un homme qui l'opposé
d'un gandhi ou l'opposé de martin luther
king
quelque part fanon c'est l'apôtre de la
violence c'est le révolutionnaire
algérien d'ailleurs il a changé son nom
il s'appelle omar ibrahim
enfin bon c'est sûr et puis on l'a les
gentils qui sont gandhi en inde et
martin luther king aux états unis mais
c'est faux c'est pas c'est pas vrai du
tout fan ont été quelque part un
humaniste ce qu'on appelait à l'époque
un humaniste c'est à dire qu'il
n'écartait pas la violence il disait que
c'était un moyen de s'opposer au
colonialisme la voyait communaux contre
violence d'ailleurs parce que j'étais
voilà une réponse légitime et quelques
pas il faut relier son texte sans lire
la préface mal an lire après frère je
conseille à mes étudiants lisez les
langues latines mais ne lisez pas
d'abord la préface parce que vous allez
vous faire une fausse idée concernant on
peut être influencée dauphin non
partisan de la révolution partisans de
la libération des peuples du tiers-monde
aujourd'hui c'est exprès sentir mon
existe plusieurs politiques obligent bon
toutes les 15 ou ou 30 ans il y à de
nouveaux termes qui apparaissent en
fonction de la réalité mondiale qui me
le tiers-monde c'était le le troisième
monde à part l'occident
et puis le bloc communiste mondial mais
il a quand même beaucoup de difficultés
à faire entendre lui comme d'autres
leaders du tiers-monde de l'époque que
ce soit le président égyptien nasser où
le président ait donné zissou artisans
beaucoup de mal à se faire entendre des
occidentaux et des russes
oui parce que ils apparaissent comme une
force émergente quelque part que chacun
des deux grands groupes contrôlés que
l'occident veut continuer à garder ses
ex pays colonisés pour la plupart
devenus indépendants mène une année
pendant un peu fictive l'occident veut
les garder toujours sous le coude sous
la main et puis le régime communiste
le camp soviétique comme ont les nerfs
veut les convertir n'est ce pas au
manque sidéré par ce que je connaissais
bien tout le monde connais bien cette
théorie que le communisme ne pourra
exister sur la terre que si tous les
pays du monde devient communiste ce qui
est peut-être pas faux donc chacun des
deux camps se battait pour conquérir
n'est ce pas
ce fameux tiers monde voilà l'espace
inexploré et voilà et dans ce petit
jeu-là fanon avait déjà quelques pas
senti qu'il fallait que le tiers-monde
ce ce qu'on appelait le tir - de se se
renforce lui même même si il appuyait
quand même plus le camp soviétique parce
que le camp soviétique et d'ennasr dont
vous avez parlé
lorsqu'on a découvert le cancer la
leucémie chez fans en le premier endroit
où le gouvernement pour visual j'ai rien
envoyé fans en se soigner c'est dans un
hôpital de pointe de moscou où il est
resté près de moi ou les médecins
soviétique enfin russes ont essayé tout
faire mais à l'époque le disait
aujourd'hui encore c'était très
difficile donc il est retourné à tunis
il a eu quand même une amélioration mais
savait que ce genre de maladie à des
émissions donc illégales mais bon il
n'aurait jamais imaginé qu'il aurait
fini sa vie au coeur du pays le plus
avérée à liszt alors justement comment
ils arrivent investissements aux etats
unis soit le washington c'est quand même
étonnant non ce n'est pas étonnant
pourquoi alors il faut vous rappeler
deux choses premièrement les états unis
depuis la 19ème siècle avec la doctrine
monroe ont toujours été partisan du
départ des européens des américains des
salles et les etats unis une fois qu'ils
sont devenus indépendants ont dit les
l'amérique doit pardonner aux absences
large du terme document d'euros donc à
partir de ce moment là ils ont commencé
à soutenir les mouvements de libération
des pays coloniaux qui luttaient pas que
bison seront opérés bien sûr partout sur
la terre battue sur la tire pas
seulement en afrique partout et quelque
part le foehn et l'algérie y avait des
relations avec moscou bien sûr plus fort
draw seraient des ans mais avait des
relations avec les états unis
et lorsque
après le séjour à moscou où la thérapie
contre la leucémie n'a pas marché il
fallait vraiment essayé tout tenté il
fallait il pouvait pas le faire en
europe bien sûr
né en france donc les etats unis ont
proposé ces les états unis qui ont
proposé est d'ailleurs devant devant sa
porte d'hôpital ça change la peau de sa
chambre à l'hôpital il y avait deux
agents de la cia en permanence qui
contrôlait n'est ce pas l'entrée et la
sortie des gens et lors de son
enterrement
il y avait un agent du gouvernement
américain qui est allé jusqu'au bout de
la cérémonie bah écoutez c'est du
calepin cérémonie de rien du tout il
fallait franchir une ligne de 30 mille
volts d'abord la détruire partiellement
après nitrique la tunisie une fois
pénétré en territoire conquis le franco
algérien a tiré le corps alors que les b
22 français mon bordel sont là et il est
pro parentis et leur justement parce que
lui il voulait être enterré dans sa
patrie d'adoption
voilà il a lorsqu'il a compris que tout
était perdu parce que les américains ont
quand même tenté quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire en disant bon puisque a
pas de médicaments va tenter une
thérapie suivante on va à lui enlever
tout son sens et m un autre sens et donc
ils ont fustigé ça fait quelques petites
périodes de rémission vous enlevez tout
le sens et vous mettez 2
du sang neuf un bon sauf que les
métastases malheureusement était déjà un
peu dispersé mais c'était pas une
thérapie dite est absurde autres
lorsqu'il a compris cela
il a tout de suite écrit avait remis un
message au chargé d'affaires de tunisie
qui venaient le voir parce que les
rentrées sous un passeport tunisien y
avait pas de nationalité algérienne
alger était une colonie française
donc le gouvernement de habib bourguiba
le président la tunisie lui a donné un
passeport tunisien avec le nom imari
bras omar ibrahim selon qui il est allé
à cet hôpital du maryland aux états unis
et là bon quand il a senti que tout
était perdu
il a un droit mais au chargé d'affaires
de l'ambassade de tunisie qui venait
régulièrement le voit un message pour
les chefs du gouvernement provisoire en
disant je ne verrai pas l'indépendance
de l'algérie
mais je veux être enterré dans ma patrie
d'adoption signé omar ibrahim 20 ans
c'est tout et lorsque ce message est
arrivé à alger à tunis par dont tous se
sont regardés ou veulent parce que la
france a installé une double barrière
électrifiée de 30 mille volts et des
centaines de moujahidines étaient morts
en essayant de franchir cette barrière
électrifiée donc gros débat est-ce que
ce qu'on peut pas attendre la fin de la
guerre
et puis à la fin de la guerre ont lancé
en tunisie bien la fin de l'année on va
aller l'antigone alger comme il voulait
que ça nous montre à quel point les
dirigeants jean y avait de l'estimé vos
fans
ils ont dit non c'est sa dernière
volonté quel que soit le prix à payer
nous y voilà ils ont pu idée
une unité une katiba camp dit en arabe
une unité de combattants et 7 capes tiba
enfoncé une partie de la frontière
électrifié au prix de plusieurs
évidemment et à pénétrer dans une partie
de sa frontière tuniso-algérienne peuplé
de chênes lièges millénaire et il y
avait un cimetière de moudjahidine qui
n'était pas très loin de la frontière
mais en tout cas un territoire algérien
et ils l'ont intégré et pendant qu'ils
enterrent les bombardiers français
bombardent à l'aveuglé parce que comme
c'est pas en terrain découvert et ils ne
savent pas alors bien sûr par leurs
espions
ils savent que là parce que quand le
corps est arrivé à tunis ils l'ont
transporté sur 300 kilomètres jusqu'au
sud et il s'arrête dans les villages en
fait les gens qui sont là dont les
espions français savaient très bien
qu'ils allaient y voilà et donc ils ont
bombardé à la venue au dessus de cette
forêts de chêne-liège mais ils n'ont pas
pu bien sûr empêcher l'enterrement mais
en franchissant la frontière il ya eu
quand même quelques donc ça montre qu'
il y avait une estime extraordinaire
profane en est
jusqu'à aujourd'hui les habitants du
village d'aïn qu'armand où il est
enterré ont refusé que l'ondé t elle son
corps pour l'envoyer en en techniques
nous ont dit non c'est un comble à sa
famille voulait le faire exhumer le fond
et le rapatrier les organisateurs les
habitants de ce village ont dit fan
lancé à nous civils algériens ne voulons
pas que son cours sur des tirs et qui
transportait nous approchons de la fin
de l'émission une question rapide
raphaël confiant que reste-t-il quels
sont les héritiers de fanon d'après vous
qu'est-ce que l'antique en algérie ou en
martinique et il y en a plus enfin ceux
qui sont héritiers de fans ont l'âge et
il se cache pas ce que vous avez
l'affrontement entre deux force brute
les islamistes et bien oui j militaire y
a pas de place pour une pensée complexe
une pensée démocratique
et puis en matinée qu'il ya des gens ya
le cirque fans quand même quelques
intellectuels qui continuent à mainteni
où vivent que la pensée de fanon
mais je pense que si fans pouvaient
revenir aujourd'hui voyez la situation
politique a menti ni qu il demanderait 1
comme quoi c'est à dire en partie sous
la prochaine fusée bout sérieuse pour
mars quoi ils risquent pas de minutes
pas une minute à ses clients qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait retenir si si quand
quelqu'un vous interrogatoires aux
jeunes étudiants ou bien quelqu'un dans
la rue ici ou à l'extérieur puisque vous
voyagez beaucoup du fait de votre vos
occupations des universitaires et
écrivains
qu'est-ce que vous conseilleriez quel
livre quel texte qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait une phrase retenir enfin ou
suggérer de fanon non il faut tout lire
de fanon il faut qu'il n'y a pas deux il
ya paris faut tout lire de fanon et ont
bien celui-là les damnés de la terre
il faut tous les ans gardant à l'esprit
que fallon a vécu à là où il n'y avait
pas internet
je vais pas la mondialisation et pas les
migrants j'avais pas la chute du monde
ou du régime soviétique
il a vécu dans un autre monde que non
donc ya pas de recette à prendre dans
l'oeuf de fans en moyenne le son le
refus de la compromission avec tout ce
qui abaisse l'eau le refus de la
compromission avec la corruption est
l'une des choses les plus terribles qui
a fait l'ex géant mais aussi l'occident
et notre petit matinik malheureusement
les fans en était une grande dame au
sens hindou du terme cette fois quand on
disait gandhi est une grande dame c'est
pour ça que j'ai appelé le livre
l'insurrection de l'âme c'est un être
dans l'âme s'est insurgé enfin la
confiance c'est sur ces mots que nous
allons qui vous quitter je vous remercie
beaucoup d'avoir évoqué avec nous la vie
et l'oeuvre de fanon qui laisse encore
méconnus ou savez on est on est on est
resté longtemps sur sa période
algérienne et six ou son métier le
psychiatre s'est volontairement c'était
pour bien montrer que ce n'est pas
uniquement l'écrivain au évolutionnaire
le dirigeant politique indépendantiste
algérien qu'il était sa personnalité
services ont infiniment plus complexe
merci en tout cas d'avoir participé à
notre émission et puis madame monsieur
vous pouvez revoir ou est vrai écouter
cette émission sur notre site internet
la première point faire cette émission
était réalisée aujourd'hui par eddy le
curieux de quelques instants vous
retrouvez le journal de la mi-journée
qui vous sera présentée par magna la
rade nous nous retrouvons très bientôt à
la rentrée de septembre bon appétit à
ceux et à celles qui sans table
[Musique]